und wir schauen auf einen Monster
Prozess im doppelten Sinne am
Frankfurter Landgericht Monster weil
dieser Prozess einfach riesig ist
langwierig aufwendig Monster aber auch
weil auf der Anklagebank Ware Monster
sitzen auf der längst dicht gemacht eine
Online Plattform Boys town sollen diese
Männer in riesigem Umfang Fotos und
Videos von schwerster sexueller Gewalt
an Kindern verbreitet haben und es geht
um Kindesmissbrauch auch das in diesem
Prozess diese Männer diese Männer
Monster auf der Anklagebank Bild
Reporter Jörg völkerling du hast diesen
Männern in die Augen geschaut beschreibt
und sie
das sind die Männer von nebenan denen
man es vielleicht nicht zutrauen würde
jetzt lassen sie hier ihre Masken
sozusagen fallen heute sind hier im
spurgerichtsaal
175/165 das Frankfurter Landgericht zwei
weitere Geständnisse angekündigt Fritz
Ottokar ein Power-User dieses Netzwerks
boytown er hat über 4000 Beiträge dort
gepostet und als er im April 2021 vor
dem offenen Computer festgenommen wurde
surf der ja gerade auf vier ähnlichen
Plattformen und man fand dann 900.000
kinderpornografische Dateien auf seinem
Computer er hatte immer
mittelungsverfahren bisher keine Angaben
gemacht er galt sozusagen als kleine
Legende in diesen Kinderschänder Kreisen
seit 40 Jahren pädophil aktiv er hatte
den Decknamen Pussy und auf seinem
Computer fand man dann auch einen Shop
für
für Medikamente mit denen man seit die
Opfer ruhig stellen konnte mal für einen
sexpuppenverkauf der auch Sexpuppen in
Kindergrößen sozusagen durfte also
widerlichste
Details und Indizien die ihn letztlich
überführen sollen und der zweite
Beschuldigte der heißt Phantom Andreas g
ein Koch aus Nordrhein-Westfalen der
hatte mal eine
glänzende Karriere vor sich Herr bekocht
ein Milliardär in Marbella lebte er bis
er dann in die Pleite rutschte und als
er festgenommen worden ist in der Küche
seiner Mutter Finger sofort zu singen an
belastete alle seine mit Gefangenen und
sagte selbst er würde sich am liebsten
ein Bein abhacken wenn diese Sucht diese
Pädophilie einmal aufhören würde er ist
angeklagt auch noch ein junger bekannten
im schlafmissbraucht zu haben und seinen
eigenen Neffen und ihm wie Alexander
geht dem Administrator von boysetown
droht dann auch jetzt hier die
Sicherungsverwahrung weil die
sexualprognose laut Gutachten für Sie
für diese beiden sehr negativ ist ja
Sicherungsverwahrung das ist das
Stichwort das andere hast du genannt
Geständnisse das ist ja die Angst das
mit Geständnissen und unter anderen
juristischen Kniffs jetzt ist dazu kommt
dass möglicherweise milde Strafen am
Ende rauskommen kannst du uns diese
Angst nehmen
ich glaube milde Strafen können die vier
Angeklagten hier nicht erwarten hier
ermittelt ja die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt die
Cybercrime Spezialisten das BKA hier
will auch natürlich ein Exempel
statuiert werden
Geständnisse in dem Fall nicht nur
juristisch klug sondern auch um den
Opfern letztlich eine Aussage zu
ersparen wie gesagt für zwei Angeklagte
steht die Sicherungsverwahrung im Raum
für die anderen Strafen von 10 Jahre
aufwärts und es wird Alexander g zum
Beispiel dem Administrator aus
Oberbayern der einen kinderpornosserver
in seinem an seinem Arbeitsplatz einem
kirchlichen Kinderheim versteckt hatte
wird auch die Aussage seiner Exfrau und
seines eigenen Sohnes denen es brauchte
nicht erspart bleiben beide haben
explizit im Gericht gesagt sie
verzichten auf ihre
aussageverweigungsrecht sie wollen hier
Angaben machen und ihm noch mal in die
Augen sehen das werden harte Strafen
sagt unser Bild Reporter Jörg völkeling
danke dir
[Musik]